didn't you invite a lot of people to
your house fans to your house I heard on
the radio yesterday or the day before
but I don't know where there was fiction
a lot you know that's true that's true
how do you select them how do you get
people to come around your gaff well
basically I got this idea before I
finished the album and I wanted to call
it the 1989 secret sessions because I
knew before I finish the album that I
was most proud of this album more than
anything I'd done before and so I wanted
to give fans a chance to hear it before
it came out like a month before it came
out and I'd never done this before but I
wanted it to be all fans who had never
met me before it had been like I've been
to seven shows I've never met you I
camped out on the street I waited
outside never saw you whatever like I
wanted it to be these people who have
been so dedicated but I've never gotten
to thank them in person we didn't get it
in but Joe now maybe next next time but
I don't but I do think Taylor you know
not to sound like worst-case scenario
Andrea but it sounds like a terrible
idea
idea was it alright well so yeah never
doing it again look what you're looking
for is no actually no you thought you'd
thought you liked it I found them on the
internet for the Tim which is it what
you're talking about yeah I would go
online I would look at their Instagram
pages or their tumblr or their Twitter
or whatever and and just kind of watch
them for months and months
yeah
and then I invited them over and they
came and they came and there have been
like there have been we've had them at
every one of my houses and when did you
first start having these feelings I
think this is sweet right so the fans
because the fans who go to do it they
then of course want to blog about it
because they've had this amazing
experience when they've long about its
borderline confusing on it whether they
had a good time or not so here are some
of the blog things so we were asked to
go to the living room sit down not to
how much I was sweating during that
moment I was like dafuq is gonna happen
I could not keep up then all of a sudden
she just pops up out of nowhere she
appeared out of thin air like David
Copperfield we all die like for real
bigger said she's sexually playing her
album first let me tell you the noise
that came out of my mouth was not human
I legit almost old mama swift to call me
an ambulance cuz I wasn't going to make
so much because they always talk about
dying
rest in peace me r.i.p me die dead give
another break we did another break as
she was bossing around rice krispie
treats and cookies and i was talking to
her mom Friddle and then i walked back
in and she was like hey babe thanks for
coming do you want a treat and I was
like I would but I think
oh this is brilliant mid-sentence she
stopped talking pointed to Amanda it
said Amanda I'm so glad you're here
Amanda died
I'm perfectly finally guys just wait for
the one she did with Imogen Heap cuz
damn that one slayed everyone to heaven
her back while listening to the song I
literally have to plan my feet
I'm gonna die
right here to the dead
how dare to have the accident what he
says is that a proper cat no I know we
got no in learning good you do your
chess match and then you kiss fetch